he's known as one of the mathematicians
with perhaps the most natural talent for
maths and it's a man called ramonesian
he was an Indian mathematician he
started with no formal training in
mathematics but just by working alone
isolated he was able to come up with all
these mathematical facts these theorems
all by himself some were rediscoveries
of things that were already known
someone new and he sent these to
Cambridge mathematicians and they
recognized his talents and he was
invited to come to Cambridge and show
off what he could do when we're filming
this a film has just come out all about
ramanujan this film just concentrated on
one achievement and it was something to
do with partitions so partitions is
about the number of ways we can break
down a number and we take a number an
integer and how many ways can we break
it down into positive parts and to prove
that I'm a serious mathematician I'm
going to illustrate this by using a
Duplo here let's say we take the number
four and I've got four units of Duplo
there how many ways can I break this
down into positive parts so I could
start with this it's a tower of four or
I could break it down right I could have
a three and a one right or I could have
a two a one and a one or I could break
it down again I could have
one one one one and there is one I've
missed there if you noticed I have
missed out
breaking it down into two and two so in
fact there are five ways to break this
down and so if we draw this out uh we
can either draw it like this one two
three four we can do a three
and a one like that two two
we could have two one one one one one
one one like that so this is what
mathematicians actually do they do it
this way uh because by seeing it as a
picture uh you can actually make
conclusions about partitions which are
easier to see the French do this
slightly differently and the French draw
them like this
uh you can have a row four like that and
you can have a row three with Row one
like that so it's slightly other way
around or you could do it like this
it's not bomb
right there and then the last one here
one one one one so it's slightly
different way of doing it my favorite
footnote from a textbook do you have a
favorite footnote from a textbook oh no
I do favorite footnote from a textbook
was by uh Ian McDonald who said if you
want to do the French notation you
should read this textbook while looking
upside down and in a mirror so I get to
say this for myself for the first time
if you want to use the French notation
watch this video upside down and in a
mirror so let's look at the sequence of
partitions so the sequence is this one
two three five seven eleven fifteen
twenty two thirty forty two and so on
like this okay so when we were looking
at partitions of four that's this one
here there are five partitions of four
so if that's breaking down the number
four or five ways of doing it if you
want to break down the number five
there'd be seven ways of doing it and so
on so these numbers get larger and by
the time we get to something like 100
right how many ways could we break down
the number 100 if we did that it's going
to be a large number it's going to be
190 million 569
292. so these get really large now it
becomes very difficult to calculate
these partitions by hand wouldn't it be
nice to have a formula that helps us
work out these partitions so then if I
have a formula you can give me a number
and I can tell you how many ways to
break that down oh fantastic and this is
the problem that ramanujan decided to
tackle so there were some formulas
before ramanusion which go back to Euler
not particularly pretty formulas but I
could show you what they look like so I
do that okay so I'm going to draw out a
polynomial using partitions as
coefficients it means it's going to look
like this one plus I'm gonna have plus X
Plus now I'm going to have x squared and
X but I'm going to use
how many ways to break down two there
which is two ways of doing that so if I
had X cubed next on how many ways to
break down three and there are three
ways of doing that and then I keep going
like this so if I had X4 uh we know how
many ways to break that down right there
are five ways of doing it and then it's
seven for x five and so on that is so
this is a very mathsy looking thing in
other words if you if you like this
notation which means sum if I want to
sum
these are called partitions of N and and
then it's times x to the power n there
you go you do that all the way up to
Infinity
now what Euler saw what's this was equal
to
this is equal to I'm going to use
another symbol here this symbol which is
a capital pi means product it means
you're multiplying these things together
not 3.14 it's not 3.14 yeah we're
limited to how many letters we've got to
use so we're using pi here for product
the product of 1 over 1 minus x to the K
there we go we've got this is from k
equals
1 to Infinity so we've got something
that we're multiplying together is equal
to this polynomial so this is a way of
working out partitions and this is what
you used to do classically and so if you
want to work out the partitions of 100
you could use a formula like this and
actually do the calculation but it's not
particularly easy but that is what they
used to do if they had to do it by hand
and it's what your computer would do if
it wants to work out partitions it would
use a formula like that ramanujan had an
amazing intuition for numbers another
Cambridge mathematician called John
littlewood said that all the positive
integers were ramanujan's personal
friends which sounds like another
nightmare to me having infinitely many
personal friends imagine the Christmas
card list sounds terrible so let's have
a look at some of the things he noticed
about partitions I guess this is
something that attracted him to the
subject we're looking at partitions of
let's say a number that looks like this
uh 5K plus four okay so if you have a
number like that it ends with a four or
a nine four nine fourteen nineteen so
these numbers so you have a number like
that you notice something you notice
that the number of ways of breaking it
down is divisible by five
so there's a fact that he noticed so if
you did let's do it so we took the first
example so we took k equals zero uh
we're looking at if it's zero
looking at partitions of four hey we did
that right how many ways were to do it
it was five ways of doing it it's
divisible by five great what about
partitions of nine so if you have k
equals one
this would be partitions of nine that's
the next step up how many ways of doing
that and if you work it out I can tell
you there are 30 ways of doing that and
hey again it works it's divisible by
five and it always appears to be the
case lamination was able to show this
and then he was able to show a couple of
things that were similar to this as well
like if you had partitions of a number
that looked like this 7K plus five and
then that is divisible by seven or if
you had partitions that look like this
11k plus six and this is divisible by
11. we had these little facts and if you
see that pattern it does seem to appear
like the next one
should be something like this partitions
of 13k plus seven is divisible by 13.
and that is not right that is incorrect
the pattern doesn't hold the ammunition
found these three and they found no
other formula like this and they thought
well that's it those are the only
formulas we've got I mean the next one
doesn't hold the others don't appear to
hold eventually 50 years later they did
solve this there is one that looks like
this it's not as simple as what they
thought 17
303 K plus two three seven is divisible
by 13 which is nothing like what
ramanujan found before I know it seems
crazy but now we know that we have a
formula like this for every Prime but
they're just not as nice as the first
three that was found by ramanujan but
this is still not the big formula that
they wanted to find let's have a look at
the big formula the main punch line okay
number partitions is one over
4N square root of 3 multiplied by the
exponential of Pi that's your
traditional Pi that's 3.14
times the square root of 2N over three
so it's a nice closed formula for how
many partitions there are that twiddle
sign if you notice means it's not equals
it means it's an approximation but it's
an approximation that gets better with
larger values so this is actually
getting better and better as you go
along the sequence so if we did this as
a with an example and let's do 100 right
we know what the 100 value was and if we
did this with 100 we put 100 in here we
would get
199 million
two hundred and eighty thousand eight
hundred and ninety three now this is in
this right area for the True Value but
it's about four point six percent off
maybe it's not the best but again this
far this formula is getting better with
larger values but I can do better than
that because this formula I gave you
here is actually just the first term
in a series so this can actually become
more accurate in fact it becomes equal
so what lamination was able to do was
use his full formula and he just needed
the first five terms to work out the
value for partitions of 200 to the
nearest integer and you can actually do
that using his own formula so these are
not particularly easy to calculate but
the largest value we've calculated so
far is something around a hundred
million million million so it's 20 zeros
a massive number and the number of
partitions so number of ways of breaking
that down is something that has uh 11
billion digits so it's a huge number of
ways of doing it the reason partitions
are important uh partitions are used in
the mathematics of shuffling like
shuffling a pack of cards right so think
of a shuffle like that but uh there are
lots of things in maths that are
actually a shuffle
um you can think of um and even in
physics like uh shuffling energy so you
know energy isn't created or destroyed
it just gets moved around right just
gets shuffled it gets conserved and
underneath that the maths is the same
it's the maths of shuffling and it's the
maths of partitions
this this is something we call a
staircase four and three and two and one
another shape that's kind of interesting
it turns out for my purposes is where I
have two rows of the same length 10 to
the 68th Arrangements of a deck of 52
cards it's more than the number of
particles in the universe okay so one
way of defining Randomness is to say all
Arrangements should be about equally
likely I'll say a sort of more practical
version of it suppose that